good morning hick it's Tuesday you
recently made a video about the overall
biomass of humans and how humans and
their livestock together comprise over
90 percent of the total biomass of
mammals and that got me to wondering how
our biomass compares to non-mammals and
it turns out that at least in terms of
weight we are sort of a rounding error
okay so biomass is one way we use to
understand the prevalence of different
life forms on earth like there are
obviously way more bacteria on Earth
than there are humans but we are larger
and also not to brag a little bit more
complex and so biomass can be a helpful
way of thinking about like of all the
carbon in all the living things on Earth
how much of it is say human and how much
of it is say microbial humans amount to
about 2.5 percent of total animal
biomass wild mammals everything from
squirrels to mice to elephants comprise
another 0.3 percent our livestock cows
pigs Etc make up about four percent
another four percent is aquatic
invertebrates for from Coral to
jellyfish fish make up 29 percent of
animal biomass their total weight is
more than 10 times that of humans and
arthropods are around 42 percent of
animal biomass so at least by biomass
most animal life is either fish or
arthropod but in a biomass sense animals
are a tiny tiny part of the story like
animals make up much less than one
percent of Earth's biomass like we are
down here we weigh less than viruses a
lot less 12 percent of Earth's biomass
is bacteria all the bacteria combined
weigh about 200 times more than humans
do and we are also dramatically
outweighed by fungi and protists and
especially by plants which comprise over
80 percent of Earth's total biomass like
from a biomass perspective this is a
plant planet with a scattering of other
life forms and I think this is important
to understand because one thing about
humans is that we're a little
self-aggrandizing like we tend to place
ourselves right at the center of the
story of Earth and I guess in some ways
that's Justified we are different from
other life forms not least because
through writing and video and other
communication Technologies we can
efficiently share knowledge across space
and time and we do currently have
outsized power our behavior is causing
extinctions and reshaping the climate
and our habitats like I live in Indiana
which people tend to think of as an
endless conglomeration of cornfields but
400 years ago this was all hardwood
forest Indiana is not a corn land it is
a forest land that we terraformed for
corn so yeah we are very powerful and we
are causing big changes to our biosphere
but we also shouldn't exaggerate our
power like we are just a form of life
the world is very big and we are a very
small part of it not just in terms of
biomass but also like in terms of time
this ginkgo tree looks very much like
the ginkgo trees from the Jurassic age
over 150 million years ago we meanwhile
have been around for about 300 thousand
years or 0.2 percent of the ginkgo's
history Earth and indeed life on Earth
will be okay without us Earth has
recovered from far greater shocks than
humans the thing is I want us to stay
around like I realize this is a somewhat
counter-cultural opinion at the moment
but I'm broadly in favor of humans like
I think viruses are interesting and
everything but I just think we're more
interesting I tend to think we should
conceive of the situation less
egotistically and more realistically not
that we are in danger of destroying life
on Earth but that we are in danger if we
don't make better choices of making
Earth less habitable for us and other
complex life forms because ultimately to
me what's most valuable and important
about Earth is not that it's a planet
but that it is a habitat which currently
hosts a huge array of life that contains
all together around 550 gigatons of
carbon of which we are about 0.1 percent
Hank I'll see you on Friday